moi je n'oublie pas que le président
d'honneur du front national ça c'est
l'année il ya quelques années
l'éloge de la griffe tapouilles de
l'occupation allemande on vend tous les
français ils ont ça en tête on va vous
voyez ce que je veux dire
on le disait ma grand mère madame les
chiens ne font pas des chats je constate
que j'ai dû mettre un certain nombre de
scud à monsieur montebourg pour qu'il en
arrive à la fin du débat retomber une
bonne concert au test dans ces
grotesques caricature caricature attaqué
virulence censé favoriser la
confrontation des projets les débats
télévisés sont aussi un spectacle avec
ses règles propres
alors quelles sont les recettes des
meilleurs débatteurs
quel impact ont réellement les arguments
échangés et faut-il à être mon boxeur
faut réussir en politique pour répondre
à ces questions et pour déshabiller en
tout bien tout honneur les politiques
dans l'arène avec nos quatre invités
bonjour nourdine cherkaoui spécialiste
en coaching et média training chez havas
paris patricia balme conseillère en
communication notamment politiques
marouane mairie spécialiste en théorie
comportementale et auteur de je cite
vous mentez ou comment détecter le
mensonge est démasqué les menteurs aux
éditions eyrolles et enfin denis
bertrand sémiologue et habitués de
l'émission on va commencer par celle qui
fait l'objet de débats
justement sur la manière de débattre
avec elle je veux parler de marine le
pen dont on avait déjà un petit extrait
dans le teasing un des derniers à s'être
affrontés à elle était à la lamassoure
tête de liste ump aux élections
européennes l'europe justement dont
marine le pen a fait un de ses thèmes de
prédilection je vous propose de regarder
un extrait un petit peu en longueur pour
voir et analyser justement les arguments
et la technique des chats car c'est nous
qui allons sauver les peuples européens
celui qui retrouvera la liberté il
confierait les peuples ils vous
répondent très bien et c'est vous avez
le sauver ou madame le pen au parlement
européen pour parlement européen
madame le pen je suis je remercie d'être
là j'avoue mais si c'est bien madame je
remercie monsieur pujadas de l'occasion
de me permettre de rencontrer madame le
pen sommes ensemble depuis dix ans
parlement européen où n'avoir jamais eu
de débat
vous me croisez beaucoup mais cela m'a
souri à la sauce ils vont se croiser
dans les couloirs de l'onu nous n'avons
pas eu l'occasion beaucoup de débats
monsieur jean marie le pen y est depuis
30 ans qu'est ce qu'ils y ont fait rien
rigoureusement rien vous êtes vraiment
d'une mauvaise foi inouïe mais cela mais
c'est moi parler je comprends vous êtes
non inscrits mais ça vous empêche de
faire quoi ah ça nous empêche de faire
beaucoup de choses et vous le savez
pertinemment bien mais vous savez on
teste vos amis et vous même nous
accordions par exemple un rapport avouez
que c'est quand même très très rare ça
nous change de déposer des amendements
mais aucun en punir et posez tous les
amendements vous voulez vous avez des
gens inscrits qui ont des rapports ou
madame oui ça je peux pas les laisser
s'interrompent m'écouter on peut tous
aller de politique et vouloir sortir je
vais sans nom il le père salésien je
vous fais remarquer tout à l'heure je
vous signale que quand ils vous arrivent
de voter parce que commande de temps en
temps madame le pen et les deux autres
membres du front national qui sont là
vote
vous votez littéralement n'importe quoi
et en tout cas contre les engagements
que vous avez pris ou plus d'exemplaires
que vous avez voté en mars 2012 mais
tout ça peut être vérifiée c'est tout
mais ces icônes et les verts celle par
défaut vous avez voté contre
l'amendement qui visait à plafonner les
aides de la paix des communes pour
limiter les aides données aux
agriculteurs plus riches
le rétablissement temporaire des
contrôles aux frontières intérieures
on a eu un vote important 1912 on
n'était pas là à 1912 en 2012
excusez moi c'est un lapsus votre vision
des choses est tellement ancien monsieur
lamassoure y avait l'ombre du grand
national monsieur gollnisch
il a voté contre voilà alors c'est un
petit extrait yahia ce que dit alain
lamassoure 1 vous avez tendance à
interrompre quand vous êtes gênés dit-il
alors marouane mérite de savoir si vous
étiez d'accord avec cette analyse
ou alors est-ce que tout simplement
c'est une technique un de marine le pen
c'est vrai qu'on en parlera aussi elle
agite beaucoup ses feuilles enfin les
comme ça beaucoup dans les débats mais
mais que pensez vous de cette remarque
dallas mais souvent alors il a raison
tout à fait pertinent l'occurrence
effectivement on peut voir qu'elle est
particulièrement net mal à l'aise dans
le cadre du débat il ya plusieurs
indicateurs et plusieurs indices qui
peuvent le révéler dans le premier temps
c'est le est là il ya un peu de peur on
peut le voir un quelques fois l'élève se
rétracte vers l'arrière la peur est une
expression universelle d'émotion qu'on
peut retrouver chez tous types
d'individus et elle ne traduit bien il
ya beaucoup de colère également
réprimées vous savez le muscle 23 il ya
une quarantaine quarantaine de mu qui
composent votre visage et le muscle 23
c'est le rétrécissement d'élèves et
généralement quand vous essayez de
réprimer en fait votre votre colère vous
allez rester
on va dire impassible sauf qu'il va y
avoir une suite émotionnelle qui va
arriver au niveau des lèvres lèvres
légèrement se plisser les zones contre
les autres comme ça ce qui va justement
laissé traduire en fait de la colère et
après on peut le voir elle est
particulièrement mal à l'aise et
cherchons ses papiers elle ne trouve pas
donc elle est là elle perd en fait la
compétence qu'elle peut avoir
d'habitude donc je suis complètement
d'accord avec ce que monsieur lamassoure
un peu peut le produire
d'accord donc gêné mais en même temps
c'est une posture enfin quand on regarde
marine le pen en débat elle est souvent
dans cette attitude c'est assez
emblématique avec ses fiches
moussa a cherché défrichement même temps
pas forcément très offensive non plus
c'est une bonne des batteries sous pas
alors finalement c'est une très bonne
dès patrice parce qu'elle a été à
l'école de son père qui est un tribun
elle pas dans le même registre
non mais elle a été à cette école ce qui
est intéressant dans ce que l'on a vu et
c'est formidable puisque vous dis parce
que c'est un vrai décryptage elle est
visiblement mal à l'aise c'est sûr elle
cherche dans ses fiches et en général
les débatteurs quand ils sont mis en
difficulté ou déstabiliser il cherche
quelque chose dans leur dossier pour
s'en sortir en même temps dès le départ
elle se victimise et sa marine le pen en
communication politique c'est la reine
de la victimisation pas vous non et elle
sait faire dans ce cas là mais là on
voit une vraie déstabilisation alors que
pour autant alain masson n'est pas
forcément excellent bon il ya ce lapsus
il n'est pas très bon il devrait avoir
des phrases beaucoup plus concise il a
des phrases très nombreuses attaques
elle est assez attendu sur la présence
au parlement elle est tout le temps
attaqué latine marine le pen médiation
donc si vous voulez elle elle se débat
face à quelqu'un qui est moins bon
qu'elle et elle n'est pas meilleur que
lui
donc ces voies la wii est intéressant
c'est que au fond les hommes vous allez
femme politique aujourd'hui se prépare
ça c'est sûr elles ont leur fiche vous
verrez dans les différentes séquences
opération parfois il s'emmêle un peu les
salles un peu ne sont pas très entraînés
parce qu'au fond l'essentiel de leur
intervention aujourd'hui c'est des
interviews et ses discours est au fond
le débat est impérieux de risque et
chaque fois que les entourages pour
éviter un débat ils le font alors ce qui
est intéressant c'est que monsieur
lamassoure utilisé un argument classique
mais qui ne portent pas dire que ce
serait si les électeurs du front
national demandé à marine le pen d'avoir
une véritable action parlement donc au
fond c'est ça ricoche voilà
ça ne fera pas bouger les lignes mais du
coup on se demande presque pourquoi elle
est gênée finale parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'elle ne cherche même pas
à répondre elle agit de ses fils mais on
a l'impression qu'à kehl sur le fond
elle répond pas mais moi je crois
qu'elle réussit d'une certaine façon à
entraver l'argument de son interlocuteur
et à lui faire perdre toute efficacité
parce que l'argument c'est l'argument
classique mais en même temps c'est un
cétacé va on voit bien qu il positionne
son argumentation
par-delà l'argument classique de
l'absentéisme haye s'est tassé de la
présence qui est de l'absence dans la
présence recettes c'est l'absence c'est
l'incohérence dans la présence alors le
déroulé de l'argumentation peine ça
prend du temps il ya des exemples et
avec son blocage permanent sont ça
ralentit encore le processus puis elle a
réussi à entraver une argumentation
pertinentes alors elle est mal à l'aise
mais elle entrave comme vous diriez moi
je dirais oui
match nul très honnêtement c'est un
débat historique
on ne retiendra pas dans les annales non
non mais dans les cours comment vous
entendez la paire cela les débats a
retenu dans les annales et bien à
quelques dents à convaincre qu'on a
repris et alors on va passer à un autre
registre aussi celui du registre
technique un de l'expert en chiffres
justement qui s'en mêle pas dans ses
fiches et qui fait pas de lapsus et et
dans ce registre de l'expert celui qui
cite toujours les chiffres au bon moment
et qui fut posture d'autorité et bien un
homme politique était passé maître c'est
dominique strauss kahn un économiste de
formation
on revoit un extrait assez savoureux on
n'est pas dans la campagne de 2002 et
l'ex ministre des finances de lionel
jospin est face à un homme qui fait
alors son retour
regardez la question des charges
sociales de notre pays est une question
centrale
chaque fois qu'on à baisser les charges
sociales il ya un récent rapport l'insee
qui est très intéressant qui montre que
les allégements de charges de 93 à 97
ont créé 400 coups les économistes le
rapport abc non mais je suis pas les
économistes de haut tout cas l'insee
existe un volet dit il c'est contesté ce
rapport lui-même
papa de continuer les coachs et alors
mais c'est déjà ça partout on n'est pas
l'université
je veux dire excusez moi venait bien
continuer merci le merci monsieur le
professeur
si vous étiez mon élève vous n'auriez
pas fait ça dépend de lui mais je le
suis pas juste normal c'est dommage
alors merci de me donner l'autorisation
de continuer votre chat go mais ça se
passe pas comme ça chacun pouvant ses
convictions voilà je sais pas si c'est
du mois mais en tout cas on ride de la
manière dont ils tentent de se moucher
mais là c'est quand même dominique
strauss kahn on a l'impression qu'ils
caleçon d'ornans la sarkozy fait preuve
d'humour parce qu'il n'est pas nerveux
il est détendu et même face à quelqu'un
qui a un ton professoral
justement il souligne stabile hot le
tonton message oral de dsk pour rebondir
et ça c'est très fort et c'est vrai que
là dominique strauss kahn révèle une
nature qui est un peu méprisante à
pergaud à peu sûr de lui et finalement
les téléspectateurs les pubs le public
dans la base élèves
mais bien sûr d'accord c'est formidable
et le public n'aime pas les politiciens
arrogant et ce temps là est dépassé
accord parce qu'on pourrait dire
dominique strauss kahn le mouche si vous
aviez été mon élève etc
mais non on s'identifie à l'élève
conducteur c'est contre-productif vous
êtes d'accord non d'une charcuterie en
fait ce qui se passe c'est que nicolas
sarkozy perd pied un moment donné on le
voit puisqu'il il en appelle à chabot
mais juste après cette séquence il va
parler aux professeurs strauss kahn en
lui posant la question quelle est
l'année où il ya eu plus le prélèvement
obligatoire le plus important 99
vous étiez ministre et là il reprend la
balle vous avez bien fait de situer ce
débat pour sarkozy c'est à
l'indispensable de bien réussir parce
que c'est son retour en politique un
après sa traversée du désert etc
il sera dans quelques mois ministre est
alors effectivement vous disiez après il
saisit la balle au bond mais là on
n'avait pas l'impression qu'il était un
petit peu mal à l'aise alors vous allez
nous dire parce que
on est quand même sur le débat d'experts
le débat technique puis lui s'en sort en
parlant des convictions il s'en sort sur
l'origine des convictions art denis
bertrand qui m'a juan mari oui mais je
crois que je crois que le son dérapage
se manifeste pas sa part sa chute
on a le droit à ses convictions c'est
pas pertinent je suis pas une affaire de
conviction c'est une affaire de vérité
ou de l'exactitude
en l'occurrence donc c'est une échappée
ceci dit tout de même là où à mon avis
dominique strauss kahn d'érable dans le
rôle dans le rôle du professeur c'est le
peu importe quel professeur c'est le
peut apporter
c'est le peu importe continuer c'est ses
terres que là il tout d'un coup il a mon
avis il se métamorphose dans le rôle de
l'examinateur par une espèce de petit
métamorphose interne il redevient
complètement l'a laissé continuer on
voit très bien tout ce qu'ils ont fait
passer des examens des étudiants
on va très très bien à quoi ça
correspond comme la maturité
technologique sanctionnant toi si tu te
réplique qu'on retrouve dans plusieurs
autres des bas rhin oui c'est vrai c'est
une posture classique c'est pour ça
qu'on trouvait intéressant de la
reprendre et attend des voix des deux
sèvres et german mairie sur le malaise
dans cet extrait ce qui est bien c'est
qu'il ya rien de subliminal en fait tout
est criard le regard et la main qui
s'exprimait un malin il faut le dire
comme ça qu'ils le bal est allée vous
pouvez continuer si vous le souhaitez
mais sarko ce qu'on voit très bien face
à nicolas sarkozy plutôt fin au départ
vous voyez également sur le visage il
est énervé mais encore une fois il est
capable de réprimer sa colère après elle
éclate réellement convoyer le front qui
s'affaisse ses sourcils qui vont se
rejoindre la colère en fait s'exprime
beaucoup plus mais en l'occurrence c'est
il s'exprime très bien sûr le verbal ce
qui lui permet justement d'extérioriser
kg cela dit peut-être on pourrait
demander si dominique strauss kahn ne
fais pas ça pour l'énerver
volontairement justement pour provoquer
un dérapage dans un débat c'est la
grande technique c'est à dire à quel
moment c'est comme un match de boxe avec
le chaos
c'est à quel moment l'infa pouvoir
déstabiliser
autres et par quel type de phrase parce
que on sait très bien et nous on prépare
quand même des candidats à des débats il
est certain qu'on les prépare à l'avancé
les petites phrases certaines petites
phrases qui ont fait mouche qui sont
restés dans l'histoire mais les petites
phrases pour déstabiliser l'aude il faut
les caser au bon moment et le moment est
important
et là c'est pas le bon et là c'est pas
le bon moment parce que finalement dsk
effectivement est un peu agressif avec
ses manières professoral le prenant
comme un élève
allez-y avec ce comme vous le soulignez
ce geste de la main et ce n'était pas le
moment du débat ce n'était pas le bon
moment et dans les grands débats les
phrases qui font mouche c'est lorsque
l'adversaire l'autre n'est pas en
situation de défense et n'attend pas la
phrase qui va faire mouche ou qui va
l'abattre d'accord oui ça déstabilise
pour de surprendre bourg de batz pour de
bon dans leur gîte du débat technique à
l' on en a vu avec ce fameux jeu de
rôles professeurs élèves souvent faut
bien le dire c'est quand même des
échanges d'arguments et de chiffres un
conte se jette un peu au visage avec
dans une autre figure aussi qu'on
retrouve souvent c'est celle voilà du
ministre du personnel de la personne en
responsabilité face à un opposant
alors voulez vous montrer quelques
exemples tonton pour autant dans
l'indigeste vous nous direz d'abord avec
françois fillon ex premier ministre face
à bernard cazeneuve alors ministre du
budget vous avez déclaré il ya trois
jours
je suis contre la mise sous condition de
ressources des allocations familiales
vous êtes contre les mesures que nous
avons prises sur le quotient familial
j'imagine que je pense que ça va hein
priori les ascensions d'édifices mesures
que nous avons prises concernant la
branche famille mais que faut-il faire
pour ralentir les 2.5 milliards d'euros
de déficit de la branche famille que
vous nous avez les il faut prendre le
problème de la sécurité dans son
ensemble vous précipiter sur la branche
famille comme si c'était le problème
majeur alors que tous les autres sont
bien plus graves que tu nous allons nous
est acquise avait par exemple si vous
avez vous avez par exemple supprimés un
certain nombre de mesures que nous
avions prises pour que les dépenses de
santé soient tenus et vous savez que ce
qu'on appelle l'ondam c'est à dire les
dépenses de santé sont en train de
déraper du tout à cause à cause des
mesures vous avez pris c'est faux mu est
énorme
évoquer landes à l'heure à 900 les
emplois publics en dix ans on a créé 60
mille emplois mais on en a supprimé
ailleurs on va rester à effectif
constant
c'est justement ce que je vous reproche
nous on avait diminué les effectifs de
la fonction publique d'état
voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle un débat
technique on commentera d'afghans sida
après ces deux autres exemples de deux
autres ministres face à des attaques
ciblées sur leurs actions d'abord arnaud
montebourg face à denis payre de nous
citoyens
ensuite vous avez pris à partie la
famille peugeot dont la seule erreur à
l'époque était d'avoir conservé trop du
gid en france vos prises de position
c'est connu aujourd'hui on fait casser
l'acquisition de dailymotion par yahoo
est par ailleurs aujourd'hui on empêche
des entrepreneurs de lever de l'argent
de trouver les financements dont ils ont
besoin parce que ces messages sont
passés pensez vous que vos méthodes
interventionnisme aux pressions
publiques servent les intérêts de la
france sont les méthodes que vous
qualifiez sont d'abord justifié par les
faits je sache
psa qui était dirigé par la famille
peugeot étant dans une situation
difficile nous avons été obligés
d'ailleurs de se courir cette entreprise
en mettant 7 milliards de garanties donc
moi l'infaillibilité de l'actionnaire je
ne connais pas je connais d'ailleurs la
saillie militarisation et est désormais
très anxieux dans un pays où déjà les
français sont divisés où les français
ont tendance à être mais n'y a nul entre
les chiffres réels et non monsieur
montebourg ce n'est pas constructif
monsieur monsieur perm je ne vois pas
l'intérêt du pays je fais pas
stigmatisant les chefs d'entreprise
monsieur montebourg
j'ai compris bledi trois fois donc
maintenant je vous réponds je ne dirais
qu'une fois donc c'est simple il n'y a
pas de stigmatisation
il ya juste des responsabilités qui sont
pointées quand l'état met 7 milliards
sur la table
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'il ya un
problème avec l'actionnaire oui y'a pas
de la faillibilité je connais pas
d'infaillibilité ministériel je connais
pas d'infaillibilité journalistes y
l'asean infaillibilité je connaissais
l'infaillibilité pontificale
mais là je pense pas que c'est
d'infaillibilité actionnariale donc
l'actionnaire a fait les erreurs on le
dit et on explique à l'opinion publique
pour console ainsi de 7 milliards pour
la deuxième écoute et excusez moi alors
d'être j'ai peut-être été excessive mais
je ne retire en rien mes propos qui
parfaitement justifiée voilà ça démarre
bien en tête et ça finit par une
concession j'ai peut-être été excessif
enfin dernier exemple celui de manuel
valls
alors encore ministre de l'intérieur
face à florian philippot qui l'attaquent
là aussi sur un sujet sensible
l'interdiction des spectacles de
dieudonné
excusez moi vous êtes juste ridiculiser
sur cette affaire là parce que passer un
mois
sur la fère d'un humoriste d'une
quenelle alors que les français ont
d'autres préoccupations est qu'ils vous
attendait sur la sécurité les
cambriolages les agressions la question
des roms et que vous ne parliez plus je
crois que vous avez des considérer votre
fonction vous avez créé un climat de
tension dans notre pays un climat
malsain
vous avez donné une image inquiétante de
vous même
l'image est ce inquiétant et
conditionnel l'immigration et notamment
c'est parce que vous avez profité
sickology monsieur philip 87 % des
demandes de retrait de retrait de tweets
sur twitter dans le monde en 2013
provenait non pas de la chine de l'état
français bon excusez de washington est
ce que vous n'avez pas eu le sentiment
de profiter de cette affaire là à des
fins personnelles pensant à 2017
et au passage de passer par pertes et
profits les libertés publiques
bon votre réponse et aux lions dominent
davantage votre vrai visage dans cette
diatribe sur des sujets très différents
sur l'immigration parce que sur ce sujet
là vous en faites par dont vous êtes dit
si vous avez vous sur les visages
il vous répond parler et puis on en
termine à l'armée manuel valls sur ces
sujets là je suis concentré la sécurité
des français et d'ailleurs vous parliez
de forbach
vous l'avez fait il ya un instant où
vous y êtes candidat c'est tout à fait
votre droit nous avons mis en place oui
une zone de sécurité prioritaire mais
monsieur yann beaufils
ils y arrivent pour la sécurité c'est un
argument semble m de sécurité quand
j'entends faire passer le message venant
pas dans notre ville là nous avons
obtenu grâce au travail et à
l'engagement de la zone de sécurité
prioritaire nous avons obtenu des
résultats moins 7% dans la lutte contre
les violences aux personnes
- 12 % dans la lutte contre les
atteintes aux biens
voilà est donc là manuel valls ne répond
pas du tout il est venu débattent de la
sécurité ben ma foi ils rendent pas sur
les
et voilà il refuse d'aller dans les
sujets qui sont pas au menu au programme
tels qu'une telle qu'il l'envisageait du
coup on a trois cas trois ministres avec
des techniques assez différente je
voulais savoir tout simplement qu est-ce
qui lequel vous semble le meilleur dans
cet exercice
nourdine cherkaoui le puissant voyant
l'ornement de boer celui qui incarne
l'autorité
valls c'est pardon excusez moi je
continue qui va lui même un peu l'humour
avec le portrait psychologique pour ce
qui est un peu de monsieur philippe on
voit pas on comprend pas très bien en
fait on n'a pas toutes vos attaques
nouveau contre attaque de ne font pas
forcément mouche des fois vous est pris
de vitesse et vous essayez simplement de
vous libérer de l'emprise d'accord en
disant n'importe quoi en fait ça peut
arriver
et puis vous avez le débat soporifique
fillon cazenave voilà on ne retient pas
grand chose je pense que le public
décroche très vite
c'est ce qu'il ne faut pas faire en tout
cas dans ce type de c'est à dire de
rester sur les arguments c'est ça de ne
pas céder 500 mitterrand qui disait que
thomas personnalisés c'est mitterrand
disait que le fond et la forme vont
ensemble dans un débat là il n'y a pas
la forme chacun dans son registre
classique
c'est comme si vous aviez deux boxeurs
qui ne faisait que des directs et bien
vous voyez bien que ce soit ce soit
valls ou montebourg il utilise des
crochets des uppercuts
ils font vivre le débat et les
changements de registre il ya des
changements de registre là il y en a pas
c'est morne plaine d'accord donc on
s'ennuie et donc on n'écoute même pas
patricia balme
je vous rejoins sur ce que vous venez de
dire mais c'est parce qu'aussi le ton de
quinze n'avaient de fillon et monocorde
le ton les deux tons donc si vous voulez
s'endort c'est une sorte de berceuses je
pense aussi que les français qui
regardent des débats n'ont pas envie de
chiffres et de choses techniques parce
que ce n'est pas le sujet d'un débat le
sujet d'un débat qu'est ce qu'attendent
les français
pourquoi les débats présidentiels font
entre 17 et 23 millions de
téléspectateurs c'est parce que c'est
les jeux du cirque du sang et du chaos
et c'est passionnant parce que les
français sont passionnés de politique
et là il s'agit plus de politique il
s'agit de parler technique de réforme de
l'état
deux sujets absolument barbant et puis
sur lesquels on n'arrive pas à faire la
part des choses entre les chiffres qui
sont rejetés d'un côté même temps le
même type de personnalité les deux sens
tandis que valls ou montebourg alors
montebourg c'est un acteur de théâtre il
était atral il a raté sa vocation c'est
un set un acteur de théâtre classique
montbourg avec de grandes envolées des
formules des gestes il est une chose de
formidable montebourg par rapport à
valls c'est qu'ils occupent l'espace
quand il est quelque part autour d'une
table montbourg à une gestuelle très
ouverte et il se place et il est un
impôt il ya éloquence à une éloquence
une gestuelle c'est un acteur de théâtre
classique
valls est un peu plus réduit vous disiez
bien pendant l'extrait je vous faisais
un commentaire sur sa manière de réagir
nous dit bouge pas c'est très bien la
vase ce qui est formidable c'est qu'il a
une technique qui est usée et qu'on
connaît par coeur excellente
c'est lorsque vous laissez parler
l'autre le candidat d'en face où le
débatteur d'en face et vous le laisser
parler longtemps vous ne l'interrompe et
jamais quand vous vous prenez pas la
parole vous ne la lâchait plus et vous
pouvez dire à l'autre je ne vous ai pas
interrompu maintenant laissez moi parler
est une excellente technique dans mes
principales de complètement autre chose
il répond c'est bientôt aucune latence
hilarant quand vous renouveler la parole
c'est le sujet quoi si comme c'est bien
sûr il a laissé parler l'autre donc ils
se rendent la réciproque et ça c'est une
technique sûre montbourg justement parce
que vous l'avez dit aysenur la famille
l'infaillibilité pontificale qu'il
utilise plusieurs fois il est le nôtre
se répète peut-être mais lui aussi a il
a trouvé on en ressort qu'il a trouvés
ils en abusent on attendait qui parle de
l'infaillibilité gouvernementale
dépilage du terrain en disant j'ai
peut-être été excessif je m'en excuse
et on se demande en voyant ça si en fait
ils changent de stratégie en cours de
route parce qu'il est gêné il s'est un
peu pris il se rend compte qu'ils
jugeaient pas qu'il n'est pas parti dans
la bonne direction ou alors si c'est
calculé anticipées marouane mairie sur
sa manière de gérer peut-être un petit
mot en termes de gestuelle qui vous
réagirez sur gerland pied et je recevais
jeu rejoindre directement ce que disait
madame sur les gestuelles ce qu'on
appelle les illustrant c'est votre
capacité à occuper l'espace est ce qui
vous permet d'accompagner votre vie
voilà exactement pour ça donne du relief
et sa vraie force effectivement c'est
que il occupe bien l'espace et j'en
prends également vos termes c'est un
acteur la force également de montebourg
c'est qu'il ya congruence entre ce qu'il
peut dire est ce que son corps peut
manifester donc on aime on n'aime pas
c'est pas le problème
en l'occurrence il est très bon là
dedans et donc du coup ça lui permet
d'asseoir une certaine autorité sur le
sujet pourquoi premier d'évadés bat pau
à mon avis en fait user était
particulièrement il intéressant c'est
qu'on était sur du positionnement fait
il ya un principe de base notamment la
négociation c'est que la contre
argumentation meinau positionne isme
chacun reste ancré sur sa position ce
qui ne permet pas justement d'ouvrir le
débat et donc du conte s'aliène voilà
malgré nos véhicules pas
également exact sur sa position autour
d'eux plus personne s'occupant fait du
public et leur auditoire le match il est
uniquement concentré sur sur leurs deux
personnes et sur le retournement de
montebourg alors selon vous c'est quoi
c'est qui se rend compte en cours de
route tous et je réponds oui ça là je
suis désolé bon alors pour moi en
l'occurrence c'est volontaire pour ses
50 dans les débats télé ici pour
répondre aux projets j'ai un peu j'ai un
peu dégraisser en l'occurrence pour moi
c'est volontaire parce que c'est une
technique de communicants voilà qu'on
peut que j'ai pu voir également dans
d'autres univers ce qui lui permet pour
moi de reprendre l'ascendant
donc il fait amende honorable voilà
c'est sûr même si aucun n'est exactement
ça ne coûte pas grand chose et ce qui
lui permet de reprendre l'ascendant
vous êtes d'accord je suis totalement
d'accord et puis mambourg découvre son
adversaire c'est la première fois qu'il
le débat tant public
woods n'est donc pas forcément quelqu'un
de très connu n'est pas connu ils
commencent par avec les histoires dont
il ne sait pas montebourg ne sais pas
comment répondre à ce réquisitoire
donc là il est surpris au départ on le
sent qu'il a du mal à accrocher face à
denek perd quelqu'un à suivre donc
d'accord et doudou cette petite
concession et ses associés moyen de
reprendre pied
mon voisin a très bien expliqué ça alors
on a évoqué différents styles il y en a
un sur lesquels je voudrais revenir
alors assez rare nous at il semblé du
moins dans la palette dont on dispose
aujourd'hui parmi les hommes politiques
français
je voulais savoir si vous l'a jugée
intéressante pertinentes alors elle
concerne jean françois copé alors
indépendamment a évidemment de tous et
de toutes les récentes périphérie
péripéties alors pardon se passe
vraiment dans la technique de débats
jean-françois copé qui se place donc
systématiquement dans le registre de
l'ironie exemple mais ce n'est qu'un
exemple parmi d'autres face à marine le
pen et à jean luc mélenchon à l'e3 sont
réunis c'est un débat lors de la
campagne des européennes il ya un
certain nombre de règles à respecter
et ça c'est pas l'europe c'est la france
ça commence par exemple par arrêter
d'être le pays le plus attractif
socialement pour les immigrés en
situation irrégulière
ça veut dire supprimer l'aide médicale
d'état
je suis vraiment confiant sa fin
bien pour des expéditions non ne vous
fait pas plaisir à bon cop bad as me
fait super beau sujet écoutez si ça vous
fait la seule chose un jour ils sont les
volatiles tout le monde parce que si on
donne n'assiste pas les gens qui sont
malades
les microbes et sympa si vous voulez
aussi rendre chez quelqu'un qui a des
papiers ou voirie fort les front de
gauche secours du front national c'est
pas c'est pas troublant je termine ne
fait pas le débat et goûter etc ou le
noir c'est autobiographique à ceux ci à
ceci prés monsieur mélenchon que sur la
question de l'aide médicale d'état
c'est pas le c'est pas le problème des
mollahs c'est tout simplement and death
est tout simplement que nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui les moyens vous révéler
d'accord attendu pour faire ensemble
mais à l'évidence il compense les amuser
en plus je vous dis serait donc tout va
bien donc je voudrais juste terminée là
dessus c'était très bien qu'on demande à
madame le pen ce qu'elle propose parce
qu'effectivement dès qu'il s'agit de
dénoncer de diagnostiquer les malheurs
de la france ça elle est excellente et
d'ailleurs à vrai dire on est tous à peu
près capable de faire pareil dès qu'il
s'agit d'en venir aux propositions de
courage monsieur copé bien su r mais
madame madame le pen faut arrêter de
râler correct 1 vous n'êtes pas obligé
d'être agressif mais vous ne vous êtes
pas obligé de donner les socquettes
c'est en 2003 abbas a depuis tout à
l'heure c'est vous je vais vous dire les
prises et même d'autant plus c'est
d'autant plus facile à voir que vous
parlez de temps et donc autant verser
dans les prisons vous rend même plus
compte en fait oui écoutez vous êtes
sans aller à ces journées soient cotées
cette caractéristique permanente c'est
raciste et agresser les autres des vous
entrevoyez conviction qu'en est il du
tout vous vous agressez vous fait croire
que c'est vous la patriote c'est tout ce
que vous proposez l'essentiel du temps
c'est plutôt pour paralyser le pays
donc je voudrais juste répondre à tous
malaisie mais prison a dit marine le pen
dans le débat clown dit mélenchon alors
que dit denis bertrand
je crois qu'il a il perd le contrôle de
son de son discours
là il a il a fait moi même je dirais
qu'il ya
mais ce qui apparaît c'est une sorte de
de pataquès alors là du coup une
dramaturgie formidable c'est intéressant
c'est drôle c'est comique parce qu'il ya
trois personnages on est un peu dans la
commedia dell'arte là il ya une espèce
de jeu de ping pong un match à à trois
bandes l'aller ça part dans tous les
sens melville a perdu le contrôle de son
exposé au départ il est il avait
installé à propos une thématique il là
il s'est heurté à une première objection
puis le deuxième il s'est retrouvé pris
dans l'aude en inde en un punching ball
et un discours absolument pas celui-là
est en fait part de malaisie il est
totalement pris en juillet en tenaille
dans le dans le dos attendait dans
l'agressivité de ses deux partenaires et
qu'il fallait des ruptures est ce que
finalement ils créent pas cette rupture
avec aussi je parlais d'ironie lancement
mais c'est vrai qu'il me paraît un peu
un voilà comment faire pour que monsieur
mélenchon se détendent un peu on peut
pas en placer une
à voir le f le front de gauche au
secours du fn on a l'impression qu'il
est revenu et il est rentré pas
redondant dans cette chausse trappes qui
consiste à surtout dans les débats
plusieurs c'est extrêmement difficile
si vous suivez les commentaires de celui
qui est à droite celui qui est à gauche
c'est fini vous avez perdu
c'est ça ce qui s'est passé a sûrement
les sondages ils voient que le front
national est devant il doit se démarquer
à tout prix il fait ce qu'il peut
ce qui est intéressant c'est aussi la
passe d'armes avec que mélenchon sur le
clown puisque je pense que ça va rester
pour mélenchon comme une une marque
indélébile c'est qaïda qui l'avait
traité de clown et quelques débats plus
tard il ya cette passe d'armes en disant
c'est autobiographique l'histoire du
clown donc pour mélenchon il faudrait
construire plus tard pour voir si cette
image de clown va va impacter sur sa
crédibilité
et puis copé fait du cope on pourrait
reprendre toutes les cellules du cope
toujours la même le même registre je
disais un peu d'ironie c'est simple il
ya un peu d'ironie un peu de distance à
quelques chiffres il n'y a pas d'âme
c'est très technique depuis longtemps et
indépendamment des problèmes à l'ump
actuelle mais je dire depuis longtemps
jean françois copé n'est pas très bien
placé dans les sondages intéressait pas
une personnalité politique très bien
classés est-ce que c'est lié à ce style
parce que c'est vrai que lui c'est
quelqu'un qui fait pas mal de débats
pour le coup alors la différence des
autres
il a fait pas mal de débats c'est
quelqu'un qui prépare il ya même fait
une émission il ya quelques années où on
le voyait dans les coulisses quand il
était porte parole
mais j'ai entraîné quoi il est entraîné
mais il est toujours sur le même
registre il ne touche pas le permet
pourquoi il en est là dans les sondages
et pourquoi il a baissé considérablement
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas su fédérer
emotionnellement autour de lui et
d'attirer ce qu'on appelle l'adhésion
affective l'adhésion effective en
politique c'est essentiel pour réussir
il n'a jamais su le faire parce que lui
même n'a jamais été dans une sorte
d'empathie un peu de douceur dans ce
monde de brutes il est resté entre
guillemets la brute c'est pas une
insulte de mal à chaque vous faites
c'est un petit ce que vous évoquez avec
nicolas sarkozy tout à l'heure qui se
met dans la posture de l'élève et qui
signale que l'autre est le prof enfin
voilà en mettant le public de son côté
marouane mérite est un mot sur jean
françois copé vite assure marine le pen
aussi qui rit à gorge déployée c'est ce
qui est intéressant de la voir rire
comme ça on lui demande si elle rit ou
céleri jaune d'ailleurs si on commence
par la chambre par jean marie le pen par
madame le pen le leur il et il est fort
c'est parce que ya pas de véritable
souris en fait c'est la contraction
simultanée du muscle buccale et
oculaires ce qui l'a placé beauvau vos
yeux et là en l'occurrence ils sont à
peine plissée donc c'est plutôt un rire
forcé pour se moquer de lui donc c'est
un rire moqueur
ce qui est intéressant c'est copé
effectivement qui perd le contrôle de la
situation là et vous voyez également au
niveau de la gestuelle
regardez ce qui se passe c'est que comme
ils attaquent réattaquer par par
différents adversaires entre guillemets
mois qui va sonner à droite il va se
tourner à gauche à gauche et qu'est ce
qu'il va faire sans arrêt va justifier
il ya un principe de base aussi
notamment quand vous êtes attaqué s'est
jamais vous justifiez toujours réagir
par une question c'est le caylar du
retournement est là en l'occurrence
comme il se justifie et forcément hyper
pied il s'enfonce il s'enfonce et le
problème il va quitter son pupitre un
moment donné regardez les ils
l'abandonnent il
son dernier comme ça il se tourne vers
un verre mélenchon comme ça et donc du
coup bah il aux bills public et ça
devient juste une petite guéguerre entre
deux d'accord à l'unanimité
l'attitude de jean françois copé alors
on l'a vu a donc débat télé égale champ
de bataille avec des arguments
techniques des postures d'autorité de
l'ironie parfois c'est à fleuret
moucheté parfois aussi en assumant la
violence des attaques
alors certains débats sont restés dans
les mémoires on en parlait tout à
l'heure il y en a eu un
notamment qui a marqué par sa jeunesse
et sa violence peut-être peut-on dire
celui de 1989 entre jean marie le pen et
bernard tapie qui vient alors de créer
la surprise en se faisant élire député à
marseille alors ce jour là tf1 avait
convié l'udf leur père le ps et le pc
mais en apprenant la venue de jean marie
le pen eymann et 4 se décommander c'est
bernard tapie qui se proposent pour les
remplacer au pied levé un extrait du
débat moi je pose la question à bernard
tapie
voilà si vous êtes le caïd est ce que
vous prétendez être si vous aimez le
sport et le challenge vous avez la
possibilité de me rencontrer en face à
face monsieur tapie vous n'avez qu'à
faire ce que monsieur arpaillange aurait
dû faire démissionner de votre mandat à
marseille et nous faisons devant le
peuple marseillais
une vraie campagne électorale tapie
contre le pen l'america de la bande des
4 contre l'avocat du peuple français et
nous allons bien voir qui va gagner
alors le message vous êtes la prépa
monsieur ta fille parce que vous êtes
aab leurs voisins notamment vous êtes un
tartare à un bluffeur
voilà la vérité et vous ne nous
attendons encore de voir à part quelques
onomatopées que vous lancez de temps en
temps sur les écrans ce que vous êtes
capable de faire dans la politique mais
vous êtes avocat de la bande des quatre
et non pas voulu venir et c'est ça le
vrai problème monsieur tapie n'a pas
beaucoup d'intérêt dans cette affaire-là
c'est pas parce que vous avez une grande
gueule et vous crier fort que vous
arrivez boli différents la seule
différence c'est que c'est pas parce que
vous affirmez fort quelque chose que ce
que vous dites est vrai parce que vous
dites n'importe quoi vous êtes en train
actuellement de commencer accusé de
nouveau la bande des quatre
les 15es à la roque aras je suis là donc
vous à l'élaborer ce qu'il est en train
de faire c'est justement ce que la
classe politique veut pas c'est me
servir pour faire des numéros de cirque
voilà un blur matamore tartarin vous
dites n'importe quoi voilà débat viril
dira-t-on pugnace agressif mais alors il
arrive que cette agressivité cette
violence soit peut-être moins voyante
mais quand même assez assez présentes on
a l'impression c'est peut-être plus le
cas dans les débats au récent où on a
l'impression qu'on a pu ce genre comme
ça de coup de gueule sur les plateaux
télé ou du moins beaucoup moins exemple
donc d'une autre violence ne peut être
plus feutrée celle du débat entre
laurent fabius et nicolas sarkozy c'est
pendant la présidentielle de 2012 et
laurent fabius vient de rallier la
candidature de françois hollande
écoutez les paroles on vient d'entendre
beaucoup les une pertinente les autres
désagréable même violente
j'étais là lorsque vous avez proféré des
accusations sans fondement entre
françois hollande mais je vais y venir
mais ce qui violentent dites vous je ne
vous savez pas si sensible resto sur le
mot violent qu'est-ce qui violent
monsieur fallu dire j'aurais voulu une
développement compos alors comme vous
voulez vous souhaitez répondre à nicolas
sarkozy sur vous me dites que j'ai été
violent envers une fort virulent fruits
venant déjà ça change des achats chance
mais vous êtes un homme pour qui je les
dis j'ai de l'estimé
mais les mots d'un sens vous dites au
président de la république candidat
vous avez été violent si j'ai été
violent je veux pouvoir m'en excuser ou
moins justifiées quelle mouche vous a
choqué à saouler je viens à mon propos
si vous me le permettez bien sûr
mais j'étais là écoutant la fin de votre
propos lançant des accusations sans
aucun fondement contre françois hollande
dire qu' il ne sait pas dire non dire
que le parti socialiste pendant des
années a été dirigeant dépit du bon sens
je ne sais pas si c'est virulent viola
en tout cas c'est faux maintenant je
viens moi ce que j'ai envie qu'on fasse
quelque chose c'est que je me suis
inspiré de vous oui parce que alesi je
vois que vous lisez au fait jour être
élu président de la république je vais
vous dire les choses clairement
je crois qu'il ya deux personnes moi
mise à part c'est laurent fabius qui
parle qui ont la carrure dominique
strauss kahn et martine aubry
on vous trouvez que c'est plus aimables
que ce que j'ai dit vous avez dit
franchement vous imaginez hollande
président la république
on rêve vous trouvez que c'est plus
humain alors on va y venir peut-être
pourrais-je à un moment développer mon
propos est aussi bon que le requin zèbre
peut-être peut-être mais je vais vous
répondre tout de suite sur le point que
vous soulevez je n'ai pas eu toujours de
bons rapports avec françois hollande et
au départ c'était pas mon candidat mais
il s'est lancé dans la bataille il ya un
an à travers des primaires je n'ai pas
eu le sentiment que vous aviez affronté
des primaires d'ailleurs peut-être
n'auriez-vous pas été désignée je n'en
sais rien en tout cas il a été désigné
brillamment il a fait preuve de ténacité
il a su dire oui il a su dire non
monsieur sarkozy je peux vous dire sans
pas nécessairement à gap pour vous que
entre vous même et françois hollande
la comparaison est en faveur de françois
hollande maintenant je viens à mon
projet voilà alors c'est plus posée
évidemment le pen tapis qu'on habille
tout à l'heure mais par rapport aux
hausses d'extrait un conte à vue en
cours d'émission depuis le début de
l'émission c'est quand même assez
violent et d'ailleurs ce débat avait
marqué les esprits par sa part par sa
violence alors ont-ils raison d'aller
dans ce registre
nourdine cherkaoui le type de débat le
pen tapis je pense qu'on ne retrouvera
pas pourquoi tout simplement parce que
des tribuns de cette nature il y en a
moins
et puis parce que le politiquement
correct alors de la communication fait
qu'on va lisser au maximum parce que
c'est trop risqué d'aller danser mais
trop c'est trop risqué mais on voit bien
ce n'était pas préparée ils partent l'un
et l'autre il ya une course de
testostérone bible là le débat avec
nicolas sarkozy et fabius c'est d une
colère froide
nicolas sarkozy veut faire un point de
fixation sur ce mot violence et ne la
lâche pas il ne le lâche pas et du coup
il dévie tout l'été autre critique pour
que fabius admettre que ce n'était pas
violent
c'est plutôt fort par la mairie pourra
envoyer à fabrice tout ce qui des
critiques qui faisait de même sur
françois hollande
si vous voulez il profite d'une
faiblesse de l'adversaire pour pouvoir
après passer son argumentation qu'il
avait préparée bien sûr d'accord l'audio
violence paf il accroche le truc et il
sort c'est assez d'accord d'un débat
tout saisir l'opportunité d'accord
patricia balme
je pense qu'effectivement vous avez
raison il ya une chose qui est très
intéressante dans l'élocution de
fabulous fab us se rend compte à un
moment donné qu'il est un peu en perte
de vitesse dans le débat et qu'ils vont
partir sur ce sujet parce qu'il parle du
temps de revenir à son propos et c'est
kim alors qu'est ce qu'il fait il n'a
rien à voir avec le sujet la danse on
accélère plus et il parle très lentement
pour retarder le moment fatidique comme
fabius et un esprit brillant mercredi
c'est moi qui dis qu'on va se prendre
les remarques sur les remarques de
nicolas sarkozy par rapport à ce qu'il
avait dit sur hollande est donc comme il
ralentit son débit verbal
pendant ce temps son cerveau fonctionne
à toute allure pour savoir comment il va
s'en tirer comment il va répondre
il a perdu formidable se rattrape en
faisant ce que non ce que l'on appelle
du storytelling en racontant son
histoire par rapport à le françois
hollande il ne soutenait pas au départ
et puis voilà et puis finalement ça a
été le plus brillant il se rattrape
formidablement ah oui oui ce parce que
c'est ça qui est frappant et c'est pour
ça aussi qu'on s'injurie cet extrait
s'écoute à quoi on a l'impression de
quelqu'un dont vous nous direz mais qui
nous fait un grand exercice de sincérité
qu'on a l'impression qu'il ouvre son
coeur j'en ai histoire c'est très beau
c'est comme une épopée
vous êtes enfin que penser aux choix sur
l'attitude de son malaise aussi vous le
sentez quand je me patricia balme à il
parle très lentement pour réfléchir à
toute vitesse et puis de sa manière de
ceux de se rattraper vous voyez
également lundi que l'exécution qui va
augmenter général a dit que la
déglutition à vide c'est une fois par
minute chez un être humain en moyenne là
ce qui va se passer va le prohibant
produira 4 à 5 par minute donc on voit
clairement ksikes express vont regarder
non mais regardez le ca permet juste de
l'illustré est le plus flagrant c'est la
micro expressions de peur si vous
l'accordé elle dure un dixième de
seconde c'est ça même quand il fait ça
avec les lèvres et qui se rétractent
vers l'arrière donc là il réalise qu
effectivement les sur un terrain
glissant on arrive au terme de cette
émission alors vous disiez finalement
les débats sont beaucoup moins violent
aujourd'hui parce que voilà pu cadrer un
plus depuis deux conseillers peut-être
moins de prise de risque vous avez un
petit constat à faire là-dessus denis
bertrand
mais quand même 100 jeunes en sortent
bien dans ce qu'on a pu voir avec des
postures qui le frappe depuis le début
ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui c'est là peut
la présence de la politesse
et l'excellent qualité l'excès de
politesse le caractère la force
protectrice de la politesse c'est une
véritable protection symbolique qui
permet de masquer les colères froides
les attaques souterraine les attaques
angulaire les les possibilités de faire
déraper chose c'est un art c'était
vraiment il faudrait reprendre tout en
doute la théorie les grandes crues du
courtisan et de déserts delà de la
parole on est dans le fleuret moucheté
d'accord donc en fait la politesse comme
arme des débats a peut-être plus
aujourd'hui qu'auparavant m'écouter
merci pour ces analyses
merci à tous les quatre merci à marie
lebon et à robin panique qui se sont
levés tôt pour m'aider à préparer cette
émission merci à diane de charme à ce
qui s'est couché tard pour la montée on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine à
l'antenne et tous les jours sur le site
de public sénat pouvoir revoir tous les
billets mis en vente la violence
maintenant elle est visé des
journalistes un mélenchon et marine le
pen mais aussi de temps en temps des
gens de la droite ou de la gauche
renvoie les journalistes
dans leurs cordes